à question des visas mais leur attente
au total on nettoie dans les buzz et
kelly doucement baston buzzer également
chez vous vous trouvez sur un
chroniqueur à mon avis et les questions
de rapidité
si je peux vous donner un conseil ne
misez pas sur doc gynéco d'un conseil
comme la salsa pas ces pauvres passés
pas attention c'est très simple en
moyenne un garçon et surveillons la
starting blocks je suis je suis à pays
d'europe
je me trouve juste à côté de la suisse
je suis je suis je suis capitaine
non non l'allemagne
[Applaudissements]
mais le prix ça marche est aussi un
scoop
si vous nous rejoignez je vous rappelle
qu'on joue à questions pour un chiffre
là tu pourras tu iras attention oui oui
oui oui oui oui oui
aller chez vous pour les téléspectateurs
ah oui c'est d'octobre on embrasse et
dom tom
ah oui oui on embrasse marie-ange bien
entendu du service urgences de l'hôpital
lariboisière que j'embrasse on cherche
on cherche une personnalité à huy ah oui
on ne fait qu a pourtant nous sommes de
nous habitons à mentaux les frères
oui
attention on cherche maintenant
11h05 eu de leurs mots ont leur mot
attention on cherche maintenant on
cherche bien entendu un président un
président français
attention je suis un président de la
vème république je suis grand très grand
jeu je dis souvent cadre de vie
l'égalité parfaite sur cette question ah
oui bah oui oui oui oui oui oui on est
sûr qu'on soit tu peux dire au revoir
mon public
j'ai pas pu dire au revoir mon public
j'envoie delphine ernotte bizot la
question s'est pas non plus à rien
contre eux au jour tu n'as rien compris
au jeu tu te sort attention les gars on
cherche un aliment a dit chez vous comme
de suzanne aliments de couleur foncée je
je je suis très sucré traite les
supplétifs et on l'attend à l'uci de
merde non
[Applaudissements]
les mecs
alors maintenant on dit chocolat j'ai
gagné de chez vous seul ou seule cas
pareil pour matthieu delormeau donnera
son nom dans un instant il repartira
également caisse avec le smartphone
groningen également cd-rom la truite
dans tous ses états